right so life coaching is a bit of an
interesting industry in that it's
generally quite expensive and you might
think looking on the outside like what
the hell does a life coach actually do
well that's what i'm discussing in this
clip with my life business coach hussain
cooper who's the author of this book the
unfor advantage very good book and in
this clip we're talking about how you
can be your own life coach what are the
benefits that you can learn from the
idea of life coaching and the frameworks
behind it to overcome your own limiting
beliefs without having to then pay for
an actual life coach so you coach a
bunch of people like what is a what is a
coaching framework how does that work
coaching so coaching is really
interesting because i've had a whole
journey of like coming to terms with
like believing that coaching is valuable
because
one way that a consultant explained
coaching to me earlier on in my journey
when i was like a year or two into
business i hired this consultant and she
was like to me okay so a consultant do
you know the difference between the
consultant and the coach and i was like
no like what was the difference she said
a consultant gives you answers and a
coach gives you more questions i was
like oh okay coaching sounds really
stupid then like how annoying is that
you ask a question why would you pay
someone so much money just to ask you
ask your questions yeah
what's more annoying than asking a
question and getting one in return it's
like can you just tell me like what is
going on so i always thought no you know
what um coach is an unregulated term
there are every top they can harry on
like linkedin is like a life coach or
whatever something coach and you just
think well these 20 year old life
coaches what the hell do they know and
you just think it's like crap so i
always
like stayed away from it but what made
the shift for me is starting to
understand and we were actually
mentoring early stage startup founders
and
we were just kind of
we didn't know any coaching or mentoring
frameworks we just did what comes
naturally you just give people the
answer you tell people what to do you
give them advice you tell them okay this
is what i did in your situation and then
you start i started to learn more about
coaching in the value of asking
questions and getting like the coachee
to figure out the answer to really think
about it it's almost like showing you're
working in like maths when you did
master school it's like jumping to
giving a student the answer straight
away isn't going to help them so
the coaching is really valuable to do
that so i think that like the two main
benefits of coaching
is
number one is clarity because getting
asked those questions back about what
you're trying to achieve what you're
trying to avoid why and then just keep
do we keep being asked why it's very
valuable and by the way if you guys see
some of the episodes of ali with taymor
and not overthinking you'll see coaching
in action because ali you've been doing
that quite a bit and it's been fun to
see um so a coaching framework to answer
so clarity is number one number two is
accountability so clarity and
accountability are the two main benefits
of coaching a coaching framework is
simply taking somebody through the idea
of like okay what are you looking to do
what what you're looking to achieve
what what do you want okay right
asking why what you're looking to avoid
asking why and then okay based on that
what do you think is your next action
what's the highest leverage thing you
could do okay so what are you trying to
achieve
what are you why what are you trying to
avoid why okay now that you've got this
data what's the next action that you
want to take
and this is this is a very simple
framework i call it aaa achieve avoid
act what do you want to avoid act
approach so how would how how would you
apply this to me let's say we want to
sort of switch this into a where we're
in coaching mode now
how would how would that conversation
start so i'll just be like okay at least
first i'll just get some context and
build imagine if we didn't know each
other build something before how are you
doing and just see what comes up and
that's kind of just getting a pulse of
the situation right now that's just
context and then you from there you get
into like okay so what are you looking
to achieve right now
and i like to leave it quite broad okay
i'd like to leave it quite broad and
then sometimes they go in what area and
it's just interesting to see what comes
up right so what are you looking to
achieve right now what am i looking to
achieve right now okay so in my head i'm
just gonna show you my working in my
head part of me is like i'm looking to
achieve a clearer calendar i'm looking
to achieve time that i can focus on the
book i'm looking to achieve figuring out
what i actually want to say in the book
i'm looking to achieve figuring out like
what i need to do to hand off like the
running of the business responsibilities
to angus who is now running the business
side of things so i can focus on the
content i'm thinking of i need to
achieve some sort of process with
working with our writers a videographer
and youtube producer to
create content that feels authentic to
me that will also potentially be
valuable to others in a way that
still keeps me showing up in the content
and not just like offloading all of it
to kind of writers because i think it's
important for me to be involved in it
and i'm thinking that how can i
i want to do all these things and also
have time to sleep eight hours a night
and have a bit of a social life and play
like squash once a week and go to the
gym twice a week that's sort of what
i've got in my head nice that's like
things i'm trying to achieve and because
i know you already and we've done
coaching before i know that actually if
you if you notice that all triangulates
upon this
sort of uh process-oriented goal well
number one one outcome goal is the book
and that always comes up when i've asked
you what's the biggest thing for you
right now who's got the book and
understandably a book is a big project
and you want to make it good and it
takes a lot of cognitive kind of labor
to really get into it but secondly if
you notice that you're kind of trying to
clear out your calendar to work on the
book to have creative space to have that
time and your it's part of that is
lifestyle design as well and how do you
and then you've got some things in there
about like keep the business running
keep that going smoothly and how do you
have the right amount of input
into your videos and not completely
abdicate how do you delegate and not
advocate basically um so yeah so this is
and then what we can go into is why and
why you're getting into that and then we
can go into okay what you're looking to
avoid and sometimes that comes up
already and sometimes people when you
ask them what you're looking to avoid
they start talking about what they want
to achieve again and it's very
interesting and what i love about this
process is because i come from a
background of marketing so my first
business was a marketing agency and
actually these are the kinds of things
that you need to figure out for your you
know customer avatar you need to figure
out what are they looking to achieve
what are they looking to avoid and
what's coming up for them and you have
to enter the conversation that's going
on in their minds and really if you boil
that down to what it actually is it's
how do you motivate people
so marketing is motivation and coaching
in a way is just motivation it's how do
you most it's clarity and then
motivation hey friends thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed this clip
then click here for the full unedited
episode and if you like that then do
please consider subscribing to the
channel it means a lot thank you so much
and have a great day